Great Adventures awake
[Music]
how fast can he go oh my God they're
going very fast they're going like 200
miles an hour
oh first person
oh my God you want to see what Halo
fight actually should look like it's
like this
usually you watch like a big movie like
this and you're like Ah that's so hard
to do it takes so long to make but guess
what camera they use to film all this
stuff
thanks to huel for sponsoring this video
stick around to find out more
welcome back to another episode of
visual effects artist react Ren is sick
so Fenner is here hey Fenner hi I'm the
B Team
Fender's actually probably mostly The A
Team yeah he's the only person who's
actually you know worked on professional
visual effects like actual truly
professional stuff so uh yeah yeah
fenders are token nuke user in the
office now so we can say we're a real
official our token industry veteran
so basically it means everything we say
on the show is approved by him
[Music]
so in Hollywood anytime someone gets a
great idea other people end up getting
it at the exact same time so that
happened last year when they decided to
redo Pinocchio and then uh two other
people redid it at the same time so we
have an incredible moment here to
actually go through all three brand new
Pinocchio movies in case you were like
oh what's missing oh Pinocchio I just
finished watching Pinocchio I still get
to watch it two more times when a
completely new experience it's nuts
[Music]
hey so Disney did their thing where they
live action it opens me
well what do you know who's this the
whale oh my God
I don't know how I feel about this water
well it's still Avatar but
I'm working like it works if it's like
cartoony water yeah which it is kind of
you have a cartoon need bug and a top
hat yeah to rate it against
just looks weird it doesn't weird is
that Tom Hanks yeah okay so you have
real Tom Hanks some elements of it start
to look photo real and then some stuff
just looks like really cartoony it just
feels like a weird choice to go live
action actor put in full super cartoon
land but then try to make it sort of
this weird blend whoa yeah wow like that
now all of a sudden it's actual water no
that's like CG water is it look at it
it's not even it's really crazy like
it's on one hand it's like impressive on
the other hand it's really weird when
his legs are in the water they literally
they don't get wet
it just doesn't stick to him at all yeah
he's wearing his besties
[Laughter]
and you know it's like
like
problems
that's like I'm all about embracing the
janky just being like whatever it's good
enough it gets the story point across
but at the same time like to see a
Disney production where it's just like
clearly like we're gonna shoot Tom Hanks
on the green screen see what we can do
later we'll do our best and we'll call
it a day it's so odd to see that in a
Disney production well it's tough when
you I mean CG water and real people is
tough because it's like are you gonna
make them wet before the water catches
them or after you know it's like you
have to make those choices on set in my
opinion it's hard to make someone
digitally wet yes you know I'm not let's
say I'm not wet how do you make me wet
it's that's hard because there's all
sorts of things on my body you have to
you have to do a Flawless track of
everything every wrinkle everything with
a model there and then rebuild the
entire environment and add like the
subtle level of glossiness not to
mention like oh by the way you need to
track every one of my pores because
those are all gonna have like a slightly
different like reflective angle
how fast can he go oh my God they're
going very fast they're going like 200
miles an hour
what has he created yeah Jimmy Cricket
is like getting blown by the wind so
hard that he needs to hold on to his hat
and Japan's hair doesn't like doesn't
mean yeah so once again it just it
really feels like Tom Hanks he's in the
studio get your shots we'll figure the
rest of it out later it feels weird to
like critique some of these things
sometimes but at the same time it's like
it's still super high level it's yeah
once again super super high level but it
comes back down to just your basic
expectation of what's real and what's
not it's just simply like the wave that
the boat is creating it seems like it's
affecting the water but then it's also
not so like right about here watch this
next shot I think is the wake and then
flat yeah and then here comes the next
one you'll see it boom and then gone
and it's just like weird little things
like that that start adding up yeah it's
like why are you doing photorealistic
water but at the same time not doing
photorealistic physics it's just so rare
to see something like this it's like
both High budget and rush to this yeah
like it's super jarring from shot to
shot because one shot look amazing and
then the next is like like that looks
great yeah it's like the artists are
incredibly talented but like the amount
of creativity going to this like they
had five minutes the concept flies a
shot it's like this is really
complicated stuff you know it's not like
this is easy to do no it's super
complicated and like that looks awesome
it does look awesome except for the fact
that like the water literally just
doesn't make anything wet right there
it's like geometry just like video game
geometry waves especially if the water
that like pools at the Top of the Rock
and disappears yeah it kind of just
dissolves off the water physics are
really good and the rendering is really
good but then like it's just missing
like a key detail of how water works
this came out this year this came out
like two weeks ago I think yeah it feels
super outdated
maybe it's because I just saw Avatar too
yeah yeah it kind of ruins it sounds
about right yeah I mean I feel like this
is kind of equivalent to Disney making a
made for TV movie yeah the fact that
these are the kind of visual effects you
get for what's effectively a made for TV
movie is crazy right yeah but are also
used now to Marvel and Avengers and all
that kind of stuff and Disney just
raising the bar so high on themselves
that you feel like anything coming out
of Disney needs to be like Pixel Perfect
yeah I guess that's like the Crux of the
issue is there's just so much stuff
being made that not everything can be
made by James Cameron
Pinocchio such a great movie how would
you guys love to check out a little
movie called
Pinocchio oh yeah I love it
I want to tell you a story it's a story
you may think you know but you don't so
our big boy gdt came out with his own
pin oak Geppetto Del Toro yeah
gdt always takes that dark spin on
everything you know he's like what if it
was spooky what if it was twisted
Pinocchio
twisted and uh actually it's pretty
great I watched it and I was like wait
everyone shut up like let's actually
watch this because it is uh very intense
but it's all stop motion whoa what
what
I love my new shoes Papa I am very glad
it looks amazing there's one thing that
they're doing pretty frequently
throughout the piece that kind of makes
it feel like you're just watching a CG
animation at moments where and you
expect it to be a little jerkier or low
frame rate and yet it hits these like
buttery smooth sequences when you notice
here there's a lot of like moving camera
if your camera's moving you need your
camera to be moving at 24 FPS yeah or
else you're going to see those Jitters
here something that you can kind of get
away with the character but you can't
get away with the camera so it's you
know we're talking about the whole
animating on ones or animating every one
frame or animating on twos meaning
you're animating every other frame and
so in stop motion very frequently you'll
animate on every other frame because
it'll save you time but the moment you
have a moving camera now the camera and
the character need to be all on one so
you have to go through every single
frame and animate it but once the camera
starts moving a little more slowly you
can kind of switch the frame rates so
it's like super meticulous in detail but
it's the only way they can get away with
having the camera move like in every
shot and keeping it like super Dynamic
and cinematic is to just buckle down and
do every frame can we see the whale
scene yeah let's see it
is that Pinocchio yeah oh my God
oh we got some CG water yeah
[Music]
the water it looks way more cartoony
than the Disney water it does yeah does
it bother you no because once with stop
motion you know motion blur isn't really
a huge thing so when you're doing stop
motion with a little character or a
puppet you know you pose them and then
you move the arm and you take another
frame you move the arm and take another
frame you know that's how you're doing
it when it comes to like older films
like you know anything from Star Wars to
anything that used the go Motion cameras
or whatever in that world of stop-motion
when it's like a mechanical piece that
they can control they can open their
shutter and then move the object while
the shutter is open to create that
natural motion blur but in this case
when you have an artist actually moving
stuff you're unable to do that because
the artist's hand is in there like going
in moving the arms so there's nothing to
like capture and that in between moment
so you enter this world where motion
blur isn't really a thing anymore so
usually you watch like a big movie like
this and you're like oh that's so hard
to do it takes so long to make you know
so unapproachable but guess what camera
they use to film all this stuff iPhone
GoPro dude no it's a Canon 5D baby
yeah that's awesome yeah right it's nuts
that's the funny thing is like when
you're taking Stills yeah
quality of like a cinema camera that's
right you too if you have a Canon 5D you
can make a Pinocchio movie this year
keep the train rolling
speaking of stop motion keep on the
lookout for a video coming on our
Channel with an investigation of using
volume for stop-motion lighting of a
Gundam character Daniel's been working
on that concept so we saved the best for
last the best Pinocchio a true story
Pinocchio a true story starring Oscar
winner Paulie Shore when we figure he's
a little juice
on the sound though all right
there you go now what should we name you
mobile game ad the movie yeah
I feel like I'm watching the original
Shrek he's just a boy
you can't even tell he's a puppet he's
just a boy is this his origin story
before he becomes the puppet father when
can I leave to be on my own
all the voice acting is like kind of
run-of-the-mill voice acting but then
each time Pinocchio talks it's like it's
like a fan dub or something let's go to
boat Great Adventures awake
[Music]
it's good
Mamma Mia wow
wow did it say at the end look for this
on DVD look around
here
hopefully you can find it
can we do a DVD bin near you
this is so bizarre the voice acting is
so bad you know I wonder like is this
movie actually like a really funny Shrek
style tale and we just don't know it
because we've only watched the trailer
it could be this could be the new Shrek
we actually didn't talk about this with
a professional animator on animators
react and he brought some really
interesting things you can look at that
differentiate
that Pinocchio from other animations
that are out there so Pinocchio
Pinocchio and Pinocchio all came out
this year all at the end of last year
pretty much yeah wow all right nothing
else to say about all right that's it
Pinocchio is behind us 2022 is over
speaking of other incredible live-action
adaptations
I don't know have you guys seen the
final fight scene from the Halo TV show
I was really excited when the show first
got announced like 10 years ago it was
supposed to be Peter Jackson Neil Blanca
yeah yeah that was like take us there
what we got it just it feels like such a
disservice you have this awesome Source
material and you're just like you know
what that was cool and all but what if
Master Chief just banged an alien
and that's what we got
it's a little bit Spy Kids very Spy Kids
he nailed it he's explosive eye shots
feel very like TV 20 years ago like
Stargate that looks like a miniature and
I swear to God that looked like a kid
was about to smash an action figure
through some blocks yeah
dude these like these guns like there's
an explosions the Sparks just animations
rough yeah you can see the keyframes
Halo actually was like a video game
like a first person video game so this
is actually like a reference oh now it's
back out oh man what is this action
directing here why are they going into
like hyper third person and then the
first person like where's what's the
reason behind any of this
face sideways now see inside of
something sideways yeah no
oh she touched the crystal
dudes that's the face you make when you
touch your Crystal
go home
pushes out for the comparison Neil
blomkampf Halo will you take a stick
Christian listening on a good note
so when Neil blancam's Halo proof of
concept came out everyone wet the bed
why well what they're able to do here is
rather than reframe it through the lens
of like a traditional film or movie or a
TV show a completely different visual
approach was taken to it and that's the
thing man like there's parts of that
Halo TV show that's like wow that's so
cool it's a Halo TV show this finally
happened but then you look at this and
this came out 10 years ago and it's so
much more tactile and real and feels raw
and like it feels like war footage you
want to see what a Halo fight actually
should look like it's like this
it's like the best marketing campaign of
all time this is so cool I love the grit
too as like not filming on expensive
cameras I love that Vibe because it
totally contrasts with like the aliens
and the tech yeah
Candy's explosions actually look
dangerous
there's like all this plasma detail and
like Sparks you can see inside of it the
funny thing is like these effects aren't
very complicated effects yeah yeah like
and once again so it's a proof of
concept this isn't like the final
effects level for a film you know it's
not I'm not even concerned that I'm like
oh yeah I hear some stock elements throw
them in there whatever it's because this
is about the summary here of like we're
talking about like the storytelling and
the filming style like the way they're
using camera work to emphasize this huge
military Space Opera feeling and you
notice that there's something in first
person shots and they haven't been
distracting so this is the first person
shot and you can see the size of guys
head to the side but how much more
inventive is it than their Iron Man like
Poor Man's Iron Man it feels like it
belongs in the world versus like oh
you're doing the Iron Man thing and or
just doing the video game thing this
right here this is what it should feel
like
foreign
[Music]
well we still have plenty more to say
about this but if you want to check it
out you have to head over to Corridor
digital.com to check out the extended
version of this video where we go even
further in depth check it out so in this
episode we're doing a lot of comparisons
love to know more things as you compare
if there's like an old movie and a
remake or a scene that's been done twice
I'd love to check them out so leave a
suggestion in the comments below hey
guys Jordan here I'm back on the couch
today to talk to you guys about our
video sponsor fuel what is huel it's a
convenient plant-based meal that tastes
great only five grams of sugar it's an
easy way to keep track of your
nutritional goals and it contains all
the essential goodness you need for your
day if you're like me you find yourself
either busy or just lazy normally it's
more lazy for me but you might be busy
you might be busy
with a long day of work and then having
to spend an hour preparing a meal there
are days where that's great but on the
days when you don't want to do it you
have an option right here this is an
entire nutrient-rich meal in a bottle to
go 27 minerals and vitamins inside of
this little puppy boy they got vanilla
they got Strawberry Shortcake they got
chocolate eight different flavors dude
it never gets old I've been a strawberry
shortcake boy since day one I don't even
like strawberry shortcake but this thing
makes me want to twerk it's weird and
then what I do I do my patented chug I
don't even come up for air I just put it
all down the whole thing in one just
it's just I always do it and now that I
popped it guess what I'm gonna chug it
because that's that is the identity that
I've carved out for myself here
it's an affordable healthy alternative
to food on the go and if that sounds
like something you'd like we got a link
at the top of the description down below
with your first order you will get a
T-shirt and a guide to help you get
started you already got a meal to go now
you're getting closed oh there it is
that's actually pretty good so click
that link check it out you'll be glad
you did thanks for watching Everybody
human fuel
gobble it up
lots of dunk well there's dunking but
once again we still always pull through
with something that is a beautiful
shining Jewel something aspirational a
glimmer of hope in this uh world look
whenever we make the show we always try
to point out that like if a visual
effect has an error or it's not quite
there or whatever like it's usually
because people just go hey I'm out of
time and a lot of money or somebody's
making a weird decision at the top and
telling the artist to do what they do
and you know sometimes artistic things
do but you know what it's fine it's at
the end of the day it's entertainment
it's movies and if it's janky it doesn't
matter it's totally okay if this thing
out it's not perfect don't take yourself
so seriously that you get offended if
somebody's like hey you didn't do it
perfectly it's like half whatever you
know shrug it off you're like cool I
love making [ __ ] I'll make the next one
yeah unless it's video game adaptations
then you should know you're you're
really getting yourself into something
the moment you go down that path so
watch out last of us we'll see what
happens we'll see what happens
I think it'll be all right I think it's
gonna be okay